what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can help decide what direction
the content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future so I was sitting here
trying to figure out what story for the
classic DC line of stories I was going
to cover because it's really kind of
cool to do one shots but I also wanted
to experiment you know with the idea of
doing something that could be ongoing
for a while and so what I thought I'd do
is I'd sit down and I would do Young
Justice now the reason for this is
because I know a lot of you guys who are
DC fans or around my age maybe a little
bit younger maybe a little bit older but
Young Justice holds a special place in
the hearts and minds of DC fans for
those of you guys who are coming from
Marvel Young Justice Teen Titans that is
the DC equivalent of like X-Men the
Animated Series like it's the show that
we grew up with it's the show that
really in some form or fashion got us
into comic books for a lot of people
they sat down and they watched Young
Justice they watched the series maybe
when season 3 was announced and they
said Okay I want to know what the comics
were like like I want to know what the
comics were about now the way this was
done it was kind of weird they were
really released in the form of books
more so than like traditional trade
paperbacks but they were still done in a
pretty structured and organized way
relatively speaking because of course it
was Peter David writing at Peter David
uh most notably being the guy who did
his fantastic run of Incredible Hulk
back in the day but we also got
effectively the secret Origins now the
secret Origins just essentially goes
over the origin story of the characters
that are part of Young Justice but it's
designed to catch people up because keep
in mind when Young Justice was launched
it was done with the success of Teen
Titans in mind and what I mean here is
Young Justice is a itively a young adult
comic book that's really what it is it's
targeted you know for kids between the
ages of like 12 and 18 it's designed to
resonate with teenagers hitting that
happy medium of around you know 14 15 16
years old but the kicker is that this
wasn't the first one to do that not even
Teen Titans were the first ones to do
that the first to do that I think came
in Joe Simon and Jack Kirby's young
romance back in 1947 uh that was a comic
book counterpart before that you had
different books like Lord of the Flies
and so on and so forth but with regards
to Young romance this was the comic book
equivalent of tapping into young readers
especially young girls who were looking
for a way to get into Comics or you know
comic book publishers trying to find a
way to bring them in and it focused on a
lot of coming of age stories about how
teenagers deal with love and romance and
you know the girl that turns them down
or the boy that turns them down and you
know the boy they can't get or the girl
they can't get and so on and so forth
and so as time progressed DC actually
rolled this over into the Teen Titans to
a degree in the sense of the Teen Titans
were more along the lines of how do
these Sidekicks basically function in a
world of superheroes when everybody
looks at Aqualad and they see Aquaman
when everybody looks at Robin and they
see Batman they look at Wonder Girl and
they see Wonder Woman and so the goal
was to kind of present that dichotomy in
terms of the young versus the old with
young Justice it was a little bit
different of course you know just by the
very nature of the title it was designed
to be the Teen Titans equivalent of like
the Justice League but this took the
stance of having each teenager represent
a different facet of Teenage life of the
people that you'll likely run into as
teenager so jumping into this what we're
going to do in this video is we're
basically going to cover a girl named
secret we're we're going to cover
impulse Kid Flash as some people call
him Bart Allen and then we're going to
cover super boy but again what this does
is basically give us this sort of iny
yourface super fast origin of each of
these individual characters because
that's what secret Origins is secret
Origins is just designed to catch you up
on the origin of a character but what
this does is this actually comes after a
story called The Secret and I'm holding
out on that to see how this video does
in terms of response whether or not
people care but it picks up with a girl
named secret now what she does is she
gives us this kind of rundown in the
sense that she basically finds herself
in The Hideout the home base so to speak
of Young Justice or Young Justice as
they exist right now with regards to
Robin super boy and impulse but when she
arrives she basically encounters Red
Tornado now Red Tornado was brought in
as part of Young Justice for the simple
fact that he was kind of this
established member of the superhero
Community but Young Justice was too new
for DC to grab Heroes they were already
super well established really good
example of this is like Justice League
International so after crisis on
infinite earth DC wiped the Slate clean
with the justice ly they got rid of the
team as we traditionally knew them you
know the flash Aquaman Wonder Woman
Superman Batman so on and so forth and
what they did is they replaced it with a
more international team that literally
was composed of Heroes that basically
couldn't sell their own books and I know
it sounds terrible to say that but they
were basically the unsellable the S
likes to call them but the way in which
DC basically bolstered the idea of uh
Justice League International was
bringing Batman on board when they
brought Batman in people were going to
be more likely to read it than if it was
just a team of random people who
couldn't hold their own books so because
Batman was in it it actually sold well
and then as time progressed they allowed
the nature of Guy Gardner was kind of
the antagonist of the team the guy who
was giving everybody a hard time they
allowed the relationships between the
characters to really stand on their own
and then eventually Justice League
International which became Justice
League Europe began to become its own
comic book title where people were able
to look at that without having to rely
on Batman to literally carry the series
on from you know one week or one month
to the next but with young Justice they
couldn't quite do that because Batman
had already done that you couldn't do it
with Superman because it was supposed to
be teenagers supposed to be young people
and so the question was you know who do
you bring in here well what better
person to bring in than somebody like
Red Tornado who was kind of dissonant
you know kind of uh outside the normal
run of humanity you know this sort of
you know Vision amalgamation type
character and then have him encounter
secret to have her tell us her story and
so what she says is somewhere along the
line she had basically come into contact
or at least as far as she can remember
uh she was associated with the Deo now
the Deo stands for the Department of
extranormal operations and what this is
is an organization in DC that basically
exists to monitor people who have
superpowers and to make sure they do not
become a danger to society the problem
with this was that secret was such a
weird anomaly that the Deo wanted to
literally monitor her experiment on her
see what she was about and then use her
to their own ends just because of the
fact that they were effectively a
governmental organization but what she
says is along the way they effectively
tried to kill her off and in response to
this impulse Robin and super boy
basically rescued her and kept her alive
now there is a little bit more to her
story and we will get into that when we
cover the secret assuming this video
becomes popular enough but what she does
is she actually transitions the story
over to impulse Bart Allen now impulse
Bart Allen was actually a mark Wade
creation as part of his whole run on
Wally West and the Flash landscape and
this is why a lot of people look at Mark
W's run of The Flash and say it was huge
in terms of what it was done that Jeff
John's being able to come back and write
a story as good as flash rebirth was
really only possible because of the
writing that Mark Wade did with regards
to the flash now there's a lot of debate
in the community and I don't mean to
stir this pop but there's a lot of
debate in the community you know whose
run is better Mark Wade or Jeff John's
simply with a flash rebirth I personally
like both I think that Mark Wade's
expansion of The Flash Mythos by
introducing the speed force introducing
Bart Allen it was really really cool I
think that Jeff John's sort of taking
all these things that initially seemed
disconnected or difficult to locate and
stringing them all together into a very
short form mini series that was easy to
digest was also really good and so it
was really Mark Wade setting the
landscape and then Jeff John's kind of
structuring it and organizing it in a
way that was easy to understand you know
it's kind of you know one leads to the
other it's sort of the circular
situation but this is why I say that we
get different representations of people
in the story because with secret being a
character that basically lived her life
under the control of the Deo she would
be sheltered she'd be somebody that you
would meet who just didn't really have
the kind of social skills that you would
expect to see of somebody her age for
whatever reason you know those
individuals just didn't quite get out
there they didn't really socialize with
people and that resonated with some fans
because there were a lot of people
whether it was because of overprotective
parents or whether it was because they
lived in a rural area or whatever the
case they didn't quite go out and make a
lot of friends they weren't extremely
social and so being able to look at a
character like that that represented
them resonated well with those readers
and so you know whether it was a guy or
a girl they could say well I'm kind of
like that but with this thing continuing
on BART Allen impulse was like The
Reckless teenager now when I say
Reckless I simply mean that as teenagers
and I don't know about you guys but when
I was a
teenager I would act and then think
later I would never consider the
consequences of my actions that led to
some very bad decisions on my part but
it's also kind of funny to look at in
hindsight because you grow and you learn
from your decisions with Bart Allen he's
The Reckless teenager not because of the
fact that he's a teenager but because of
how he was raised what happens here is
we pick up with his origin story and of
course he's talking to you know one of
his friends the only girl that really
knows his identity you know is Bart
Allen um but it's again him just kind of
refreshing us with the story and we're
told that he's basically the grandson of
Barry Allen and Iris West from in the
future and the result of this is that
when he was born and he had speed force
Powers he couldn't control them in the
same way that like Wally West and Barry
Allen were able to control them instead
it was literally just you know 100 mph
or it was Zero now I don't mean to say
that he can actually Run 100 Mil an hour
that's mean to say in terms of speed
either he was on at 100% or he was not
moving at all there was no real way for
him to be able to control his abilities
and so what happened was he was
basically taken and thrown into a
virtual reality environment where he was
taught how to use his powers he was
taught how to move around effectively
and work within the confines of his
abilities restrictions in terms of his
inability to control how fast he was
going the problem with this is that this
created recklessness in the sense that
he never had to deal with consequences
it was virtual reality there was no
chance that he was ever really going to
die and if there was he was always
yanked out before that would happen and
so because of this he's never really had
to experience true consequence that is
to say losing his life now once he was
brought back to the past and once he was
thrown into the superhero landscape this
was a way for Marvel to basically say
okay let's give him some development
show him what the real world's like
let's show his character progressing as
time goes on and it was really cool in
terms of how it was done the kicker to
this is that his recklessness was
effectively his personality now and so
while he had been a little more cautious
while he had been a little more careful
in terms of the kind of things that he
did in the end more often than not he
never thought things
through but the kicker to this is that
Wally West was able to basically
stabilize his molecular structure in the
sense that he was no longer moving at
super speed all the time but he also had
some measure of control over his
abilities and so it was really DC coming
along and saying okay let's grab this
character and let's make him more like
the other flash characters you know
let's make him more part of the flash
family instead of this outlier that's
out in left field and doesn't really
have a place to call his own in terms of
how he relates to the flash family the
funny thing about this though was that
he was also brought under the tutelage
of Max Mercury and even Bart Allen
himself says that Max Mercury is kind of
like this zen master of speed now the
reason for that is because Mark Wade I
believe it was had established that Max
Mercury was effectively the first first
person to be able to use the speed force
now for those of you guys who are really
really familiar with Jeff John's idea of
flash rebirth this is where the things
don't quite seem to reconcile at least
as far as I've been able to tell there's
no reconciliation here what Jeff Johns
did is he said that Barry Allen had
basically been creating the speed force
from the first time he gained his powers
up until the time that he basically died
during crisis on infinite Earth or at
least it was thought that he died he'd
been generating the speed force and so
by the time he basically died he had
created it and he went into the speed
Force which is where he had been the
entire time between crisis on infinite
Earth and his return during final crisis
going into flash rebirth under Jeff
John's the problem with this is if Max
Mercury was the original Speedster able
to access the speed force then how does
that work well the easy solution here is
to say well the speed force is
multiversal the speed force stretches
all throughout space and time and so if
Barry Allen had been creating the speed
force in the present it had just
basically resonated throughout all
existence which means that Max Mercury
will be able to touch it in the past
it's one of those weird kind of mind
bending sort of things but that's the
best way I've been able to analyze it
granted there may have been something
that I miss in Jeff John's flash rebirth
that would connect those two things and
if there was feel free to post it down
in the comment section but the overall
just behind this is sort of impulse
being a young Reckless teenager who
realizes the value of having a mentor
but also hates having a mentor because
he basically just doesn't like being
told what to do he doesn't like to be
limited he doesn't like to be told you
can't go do this you can't go do that he
just wants to go out do his own thing
and then whatever happens happens and so
of course you know with impulse saving
his friend from bullies secret origin
effectively ends with these bullies
running up on them trying to get him
back impulse basically you know
overpowering them from behind taking
them out and that's really the end of
that and so what this does is this
transitions over to super boy now this I
think is actually where things get
pretty cool when it comes to the idea of
Young Justice because a super boy in my
mind was always kind of this weird
situation like super boy before New 52
was always kind of this thing where he
was like this leftover Relic from a
previous era in DC that they never
really knew what to do with now I'm
probably going to invoke the ey of some
DC fans by saying that but I always kind
of felt that was the case I always sort
of felt like after the death of Superman
there was really nothing left to do with
super boy you know what do you do with
him I mean you know the reign of
Superman is over the man of Steel's back
what do you do with him well the genius
idea of Peter David was put him on a
team put him on Young Justice and just
have him go from there and that's
actually a genius idea I really really
like that because I feel like with his
character effectively being a teenager
it gives him kind of a place to go now I
wouldn't say he's like the most mature
of teenagers in general but I would say
that he seems to be the most capable now
again we still get this idea of his
origin story but he's actually in the
middle of a training session when he
gets his origin but something else that
I'd like you to notice here is that
super boy really seems to be like the
jokester of the team like he seems to be
the guy that you know he has it where it
counts but he also he's pretty jovial he
likes to crack jokes he likes to imagine
he's in movie sequences you know going
with movie stars of course he makes
reference to Selma hyek which is the way
it should be I mean you know Selma hyek
should always be anyone's Choice when it
comes to hey you know if there was a
celebrity I could get with would it be
Selma H now one of these guys named
dubbilex I think it's how you pronounce
his name says he was a Nev Campbell fan
this is 1998 1999 guys Nev Campbell was
never hot she was never good-look all
right you could make an argument for
wild things but we all know that Denise
Richards was like the hot chick in wild
things go look at Denise Richards in
1998 oh my god dude she was super hot
back in 1998 this is getting weird
moving on
but again you know we're just kind of
given this little bit of a backstory
about him what we're basically told is
that when Superman had died there was
this power vacuum Superman was such an
iconic character that superheroes around
the world realized that he was needed it
was one of these things where it was
only after he was gone that the world
realized the influence he had on the
superhero Community as sort of this
leader as this super powerful guy even
if nothing more than just a symbol they
could rally behind and so the goal was
to basically clone Superman using
Kryptonian DNA the issue with was that
project cadis didn't really have access
or couldn't crack the Kryptonian genome
and so because of this they couldn't
create a tried and true Superman clone
instead what they did was the next best
thing the Project's director a guy named
Westfield essentially cloned a super boy
using a hybrid of his own DNA along with
modifications now this is all really
done in kind of a hush hush thing but
the idea was that once he got out into
the regular world this was his
introduction into reign of the Superman
this was him coming into the post Death
of Superman landscape when he didn't
want to be called Super Boy you know
when he wanted to be called like the
Metropolis kid or something along those
lines the funny thing about this though
was that DC had to find a way to also
differentiate him a little bit because
they were going to bring Superman back I
mean that was always something that was
going to happen and so they couldn't
basically say hey here's this super boy
that has the exact same pow as of
Superman because the possibility was
that with DC trying to make Superman
relevant by killing him and bringing him
back if they had made Super Boy a clone
of Superman then when Superman came back
people wouldn't care they'd say well we
have this young vibrant super man now we
don't care about the old guy we care
about the young guy and so they kind of
changed him up they said he has like
tactile telekinesis meaning he can
basically move objects that he touches
it allows him to fly he's got super
strength and so on but he lacks things
like heat vision he lacks things like
x-ray vision he lacks things like super
Heering a lot of the traditional powers
of Superman that were relatively unique
to him really up until like Martian
Manhunter those Powers were lacking in
his character because it was a way for
DC to say yeah he's super boy yeah he's
a superman but he's not the Superman it
was kind of like this halflife thing
that you only ever create something that
has a halflife and the halflife always
just keeps getting cut in half as time
progresses it's kind of weird but the
goal here was to introduce them in a way
that could give people something that
would basically hold them over until
Superman returned the issue with this
was that again once Superman came back
they were basically trying to find a
place to put him they were trying to
find some place to send him and so
having him taking up residence as part
of Young Justice gave him the
opportunity to shine alongside a team as
well as kind of create this situation
where the question was where will he go
next and what I mean by that is because
of the fact that he didn't have a lot of
the traditional powers of Superman as
super boy the idea was that somewhere
along the line those Powers would
manifest that the genes were there for
them to activate but it was designed for
them to manifest in the same capacity
that Superman's powers manifested over
time because keep in mind Superman
didn't just suddenly one day have all of
his powers they came on in different
sports as time went on kind of like what
we're seeing right now with regards to
Jonathan Kent and Superman rebirth and
Action Comics rebirth but the issue is
that he effectively can't age and so it
was kind of like DC saying okay he may
have these Powers somewhere along the
line but if they're designed to come
into play as he grows older well then
he'll never have them because he'll
never grow older and so again it was
kind of locking him at the point that
where he was now the reason why DC kept
him as a young person was because people
loved him people loved the idea of super
boy I mean he was he screamed 1990s when
he first showed up the leather jacket
the circular glasses I mean he was young
he was hip he was cool he was vibrant
people loved him people thought he was a
really really really cool character and
his time progressed especially during
his time as part of Young Justice even
with his earring which even in 1999
people weren't wearing those things
anymore um he he was still really fun
for a lot of people and a lot of fans
really really enjoyed him but again me
what this did is this basically kind of
wrapped back around it said okay here's
where we stand with young Justice at
least with these particular Origins here
are the characters that we have right
now we've got secret who is basically a
girl who's been sheltered we have
impulse who's the Reckless one and we
have super boy who's kind of like the
kind of experience a little bit more
experienced but also you know kind of
the jokester has it where it counts kind
of guy to a degree I don't know that
makes any sense to you guys but if you
guys enjoyed this video and you're new
here to Comics explain make sure you hit
the Subscribe button to become part of
the Rob core if you enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and leave a
comment down below let me know whether
or not you guys are interested in seeing
any more of the secret origin stories
for these members of Young Justice
because again it goes into the main
series itself this just kind of gives us
a jumping off platform it gives us a
place to start with regards to who the
characters are as part of the team but
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and I will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
for